So, Charles, what did we learn about regression?
>> well, we learned a bunch of interesting historical facts about
where the word came from, which I thought was interesting anyway.
>> Oh good.
>> We learned about model selection and overfitting.
And underfitting. And fitting in general, cross validation.
>> Talked about, how to do linear and polynomial regression.
>> Yeah.
>> That the best constant, that the best
constant in terms of squared error is the mean.
>> Mh-hm
>> These little cocktails for that.
>> Well we also did the same thing for well we talked about
the process for how you do it in genreral for any polynomial function.
>> I think that's everything.
>> Well one more thing, and we talked a little
bit about representation, and how to make that work in regression.
>> Great, we talked about input representations
and what some of the issues are. There.
>> Yeah.
>> Great, I think that's, I think that's a good amount.
>> I think so, too.